hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well after making the
case with his first argument that love
is the most lovely or beautiful the most
kalos of all of the gods are divine
forces and the Thummim is going to make
a second argument intended to complement
and reinforce this this other one in his
speech and it's going to make reference
to the goodness or the virtue the RNA
the moral excellence of love so we have
love as kalos and we have love as
Agathis putting these two together is
very natural for the great the beautiful
and good Agathon is trying to provide us
now with the second half of that the way
he's going to do that is he's going to
talk about each of the four what we call
cardinal virtues it's very interesting
here that Agathon is going to pick up
precisely on the four virtues that
socrates is you know acting as the
mouthpiece for Plato we'll talk about in
other places there is a fifth virtue
piety Josias
which gets brought up as well in in
several other dialogues particularly the
Euthyphro but also the protagonists it
plays a role in the Republic but it's
not being discussed here in part because
it
it really makes sense to worry about
love as being pious since love is at
least as far as the assumption goes here
one of the gods so we're gonna talk
about justice des cailloux soon a jury
sees temperance so frozen a courage and
the way also sometimes rendered as
manliness and wisdom or Sophia not
phronesis which is a practical wisdom
but wisdom in in gemo
wisdom in the broadest sense plato by
the way will use both of those terms in
many respects without distinguishing
between them as synonyms so how is the
idea that I'm going to argue that love
actually possesses all of these moral
virtues and possesses them to the
greatest extent his arguments are not
particularly good but don't be too
concerned before we actually see what
the argument is about critiquing it
immediately we'll come back and and
critique these after we're done so
justice dko soon a right the state of as
it's often put giving everybody what
does their due does dog head that he
says that love never injures anyone so
that's one important part love is also
never injured now why would he bring up
love being never injured well when we
are injured that's when we have a
tendency to want to retaliate and don't
do some injustice in return right when
we get angry we often go go beyond
proper bounds he also sends that love is
it doesn't involve force at all via or a
compulsion rather everybody serves love
willingly everybody serves love the
Greek for that is hate hon you know
accenting to it agreeing to it when we
when we do things out of love we may
feel a sense of compulsion but we also
are doing what we want to do so he's
saying here that because of that love is
not actually compelling anybody to do
anything against their will and so love
is in fact just
the essence of justice many of the
Greeks felt lady in these mutual
arrangements where they were consensual
the one would say I agree to this I
agree to this agreements as we would
call them so he's saying wobba actually
follows along with that love is is in
some respect the source of that sort of
thing
what about temperance in the vlog
tempera here's an interesting argument
well what is temperance at least the way
the Greeks understood or moderation its
mastery or rulership Crotty a' /
pleasures and desires or appetites and
love itself is one of those desires or
pleasures if you actually get what it is
that you're desiring and so if love is
the most powerful of all these no lesser
desire say the desire for wealth the
desire for food the desire for
reputation the desire to build a great
monument and you know the desire to have
a car tricked out in various ways none
of those can actually hold a candle to
love so if you feel love love is going
to result in the mastery of those
desires right because if they get in the
way of love love takes priority they
take a back seat so by love being the
most powerful that means that love
becomes the master of all these other
pleasures and desires which means that
love is like super temperance it is
temperance to the highest degree because
what is it to be temperate its to rule
pleasures and desires now notice that
love itself it is still one of these
desires courage or manliness I'm the
data here in fact he brings up one of
the most manly men were actually manly
gods of ancient Greece a guy who is just
out of control the the guy who you know
if he was a human being and beginning in
barroom fight and that's Aries the god
of a blackout of war
bloodthirsty one and love according to
the story takes Ares captive how so
because Ares conceives a love or a lost
er designer for the goddess of love
Aphrodite and it's the force of love
which controls Ares in this case so Ares
becomes the captain becomes a captive
love is the capped or the capped or is
stronger than the captive so love is
even stronger than the bravest and the
strongest which means that love then has
to be even more brave and even stronger
than the Ares
so that sort of elevates them to the
very top sort of like going into you
know a situation with a bunch of tough
guys and you pick out the toughest guy
there and you beat them up that means
you're the toughest right that's the
argument that Agatha is making here
essentially now the reason why I put
wisdom over here by itself is because
Agathon is going to devote more space
and more of his his thought to telling
us why love really has wisdom this is in
a certain sense a reflection of Plato
who tends to give wisdom the highest
priority among the virtues as well so
it's kind of an interesting point to
follow up on why is love wise well
here's the central thing long actually
knows things because the evidence that
you know something is that you can make
something happen or you can teach that
thing to somebody else
lovey says is making reference to his
own profession love is a poet and unlike
other poets who can't quite explain what
what they're doing as we see this in
many other Platonic dialogues
love is a poet who can make others who
are not poets into poets love can do
what it is that plano demands that
anybody who really knows something want
to be able to do
he can teach it he can produce it in
another how does love make the rest of
us poets well when we follow them off
then we you know get all you know we
start thinking about love songs and
poetry and and doing poetic gestures we
would call those romantic gestures we
start producing we start doing things
right a point in Greek is a word that
means to produce or to do it's broader
than just you know sitting down writing
verses or stuff like that showing up
with flowers would be in a certain sense
a type of poetry not a very eloquent
poetry unless the flowers are very
artfully arranged but nonetheless poetry
in some sense so a lot of those able to
take people who are not originally poets
and turn them into poets so I'm like you
know if you want to say that you really
understand culinary arts can you turn
somebody else into a chef if you really
really understand construction can you
take some guy off the street and you
know teach them some some trades so he
can actually build a house
lunk can do that furthermore living
things everything that we see including
ourselves and you know I mean the Greeks
didn't really think in these terms but
if we wanted to get kind of silly with
it you know all the parasites living on
us and the bacteria in us they're all
reproducing well the bacteria are
reproducing through sex but everything
else pretty much is so they're all
reproducing through love even the
planets are right you know male pollen
eggs fertilization all that sort of
stuff that's all being produced by love
so love is you know in a certain sense
the the ultimate botanist and zoologist
and I don't know what else we want to
say sexologist perhaps the arts and the
sciences is even more interesting all
the arts and the sciences
Agathon says are brought forth by love
and he gives examples of a number of
different gods Hephaestus the
metalworker
originally you know starts to become a
Smith because he loves the stuff that
he's working with Apollo and gets you
know triple credit he is what we call a
triple threat
archery medicine divination Athena its
weaving
though she should also get strategy from
from this guy you know clearly given
that you know she plays a role in that
and we can go on and on and on
presumably areas really laws hewing
people on the battlefield
Zeus loves ruling and introducing order
to things so even the political art is
in a certain respect produced by love by
the force of love he observes another
thing too that's very interesting about
these you know Arts and Sciences are
crafts those who have passion he says
succeed and become famous those who
don't have that those for whom you know
their craft is just a day job they don't
achieve that we don't really like their
work it's love that allows us to produce
the greatest kinds of works that
actually draw people's attention where
they say that's really something so long
possesses wisdom because of all of these
factors now let's think about these
assertions for a moment is this a very
good argument for for justice never
injures yeah I would say if love never
does injure anybody that's that's
probably a good argument for justice
because part of Justice is not injuring
people not compelling people into things
that they don't really want to do well
you know one can actually make us do
some really dumb stuff it's not clear
that love doesn't make us do things that
we don't want to do at least you know in
our own experience so I don't know that
this would hold I think we can come up
with plenty of examples in ancient
Greece that would be counter examples to
this temperance love itself may master
all the other desires but it is still a
raging desire and if it's the strongest
of desires Plato is going to be rather
suspicious of it as a desire and say
that unless you know something is
governing at it's going to get us in
trouble so it's not clear that love
actually brings about temperance as a
matter of fact people often go away over
the limits when it comes to acts and and
you know behavior that's motivated by
love this is this whole argument about
being able to get the drop on Aries for
courage that doesn't really hold you can
easily be a coward yeah do in the
toughest guy who is the most brave
simply being able to to master him or or
capture him doesn't really make you
brave as a matter of fact it might show
depending on how you do it you're your
own cowardice as a result wisdom this is
an interesting argument over here is it
a strong argument isn't one that we
should we should buy into or is is it at
best sort of allegorical you know there
are elements of it that do seem quite
interesting and that do map onto some of
our experience but just let's take the
last one is it possible to be motivated
by love to be passionate about your
craft and still to be a failure it
happens all the time as a matter of fact
unless you actually have knowledge all
that passion is probably just setting
you up for either failing or being
exploited by somebody else
you know love can can you know produce
all these things in in the natural world
but it's not necessarily love in the
sense that we're talking about here so
there's a bit of equivocation taking
place as well it's hard to see something
that is purely instinctual like sexual
activity among insects actually results
in you know love the God being wise so
none of this really holds up that well
when we look at it but it is at least a
rhetorical level a really wonderful
portion of the speech because he's
claiming that love really does possess
all of these virtues and he's trying to
provide arguments for why that would be
the case